so hello everybody we are back with
richard roland i know everybody is
excited to see what is it that we're
going to talk about today
um and so after our trek through
ethiopia we are now moving back to
western europe
what we're going to do is we're going to
we've been talking a lot about sacred
history and about how these religious
patterns kind of manifested themselves
uh
in the way that people understood
themselves and their identities and but
now we're going to look a little more at
this secular world and we're going to
look at a tradition called the nine
worthies where even in secular spaces or
in kind of more common spaces there was
this desire to connect their own society
through memory through celebration with
different characters in the past both
from the pagan world and the christian
uh
religious world uh you know trying to
kind of
continue on this vision of universal
history that we've been proposing since
the beginning
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
and so richard i know there were a few
things you wanted to say before we start
there are a few things you wanted to
kind of come back on first of all
congratulations on the the conference on
the token conference that you went to i
hear some people we're inviting symbolic
world people were there yeah we had a
great turnout of symbolic worlders so
shout out to all of you guys uh just a
bunch of really delightful people we had
a bunch of people for whom this was
their first time ever stepping into an
orthodox church
which was really awesome and i think was
made a really big impression on people
we had a cool time the talks which i
think will be
very resonant for
your audience uh will be up on the
amitool podcast whenever they get
uploaded by audio producer
um
the uh we did some other really cool
stuff we
got to read the dream of the rude which
is an anglo-saxon uh devotional poem to
the lord's cross
uh actually in front of a of a relic of
the lord's cross and and and venerate
that relic which was basically
i mean it was just sort of like peak
my life like like it was just sort of
like one of the best parts
ever happened yeah well everything
coming together token it was it was
poetry and yeah
yeah it was it was very much and it was
nice because we sort of like went from
talking about the stuff to to being able
to participate it in it in in a way yeah
and it was it was really cool so uh
anyway it was a great time a huge thanks
to father andrew uh the community there
with st paul's and the same basil
society for
hosting me uh feeding me putting me up
and uh just treating me
so well and uh it was a great time
that's great that's great and so as you
saw i also discussed with uh
deacon enoch you know an ethiopian
deacon who's also american who kind of
expounded a little more of ethiopian
tradition from the inside and since our
whole kind of exploration of of
ethiopian orthodox you've had some
amazing reactions from ethiopian
christians people from all over and uh
you know people helping us understand
more giving us some few precisions that
richard wants to we is going to look
over some few precisions we need to to
make maybe yeah so this came from
uh tadios so tadios thanks for uh thanks
for reaching out
and uh i have to say
one of my favorite things in life is
actually being
graciously corrected
um i say graciously okay but um but i
really do uh
uh try to keep a sort of beginner's mind
about these things and um
there's definitely stuff that i was
picking up by you know from reading
different books and different academic
papers and things like that but i don't
have that same insider perspective and
so tadios reached out to uh correct a
few things that we said that i said in
our last ethiopia video about ethiopian
saints and hagiography and i just wanted
to go over them real quick
um because they're actually super cool
and they actually make the overall point
that we were trying to make better than
the things that we said so his first
thing that he wanted to mention was the
uh i i said something about one of one
of the saints who whose leg sort of fell
off and uh
my
impression and this was based on an
academic paper that i'd read on on the
subject my impression was that the leg
was not actually a big deal and it
wasn't really venerated and i mentioned
this mostly because it seemed weird and
very like a not what christians do but
also be like very kind of non-ethiopian
right ethiopia is all about like taking
the the remnant of the thing and like
preserving it right
and so it turns out this was just a
totally
mistaken thing uh uh
about which you know my source was
completely wrong and so what he's uh
what he says is he talks about um saint
uh techlee heimannot i think
um uh uh he's known to have prayed for
22 years while standing still
um so very much his legs would be
important actually yes yeah so his legs
would kind of come up
um and uh seven years he prayed only
standing on seven of those years he
prayed only standing on one foot and so
what he had done of course we have like
stylized in people like this so to stop
him from seeding or leaning to the side
uh it says that he put six like arrows
or spears
um on either side of him so that if he
got tired and leaned to one side he'd be
pierced by them
and tradition describes that whenever
his body got weaker and he leaned to the
side the arrows would pierce him and
keep him straining standing straight for
years praying in in this cave
um and so this led to one of his legs
below the knee getting broken off from
his body like you'd imagine might happen
um and uh
he said apparently that particular bone
not only was it kept but it actually has
its own feast day on the ethiopian
calendar just for that leg
um which is pretty awesome
um i love stuff like this like we have
we have like the
like two different feasts around the
head of yeah and things like the chains
of saint peter and and what not uh but
this is really this is really fun yeah
but they'll do us with the head of st
john the baptist too i saw some icons in
ethiopia of the head of saint john the
baptist like with wings like flying
around to haunt the people that
decapitated him
that is
my gosh that's so great
uh and actually one of the cool things
he he did include a picture of an icon
of this particular saint
and uh of course the thing the first
thing that i noticed in the icon was
just the fact that the saint has six
wings you know he's a seraphim yeah um
and uh
so something about like his burning
intensity and his love for god
um so anyway that was really cool there
was um
[Music]
um there were some other corrections in
here i mean some of these stories were
are just like uh crazy i'll i'll read
what he says about this
he said there are
sub-traditions within the tradition
of
you know the veneration of a saints
relic so for instance there's a famous
monastery called saint melchizedek who
is a saint named after the old testament
priest
god gave him this covenant which makes
everyone who is buried
near the monastery not just the saints
uh makes their relics be preserved as
incorrupt so that they don't decay
um and he says and i'm just going to go
off of what he says here i haven't
looked this up at all
it says last i've heard some university
professors tried to test the hypothesis
on the hagiography and bury someone half
like their body like half in half
outside
the
borders of the monastery
and the portion of the body that was
inside the monastery premise didn't
decay and the other portion did like
every other burial and he doesn't
actually include some pictures here
um and there's some other really crazy
stuff of like ossuaries where like the
bones of saints just sort of like show
up and people like yeah we don't
actually know who these guys are or or
how they got here yeah they're saying
they got to be saints
um
so yeah and he corrected us in a few
things like because we said some some of
the people we mentioned were part of the
the original yeah yeah i think
specifically the same with the wings
that you've mentioned yeah that he
wasn't he was an ethiopian saint yeah so
a few things like that so thanks
everybody for correcting us when we get
our details wrong and so so these nine
saints will lead us in a way in a very
strange surprising way into the nine
worthies today
so richard take it yes it could take it
so that's that was a nice transition um
so
actually
you could probably just do an entire
video and i know there's a whole section
in i think matthew's book about the
symbolism of the number nine
uh which is very important in the
ancient world in the middle ages it's
very important in dante like dante's
whole metrical scheme is around the
symbolism of the number nine
um
i i mean it's not hard to understand
it's a triad of triads right
um and uh so it's a sort of a a heavenly
fullness right
and uh so there are of course very
famously there are nine ranks of angels
uh mentioned in the scriptures described
by saint dionysius the areopagite
and then also in the orthodox church
there are nine ranks of saints
and so
i don't know how many people know this
uh but if there's there's actually like
if you think liturgy is long
the priest actually has his own liturgy
that he has to do to prepare for
everyone's liturgy right so it's
sometimes called like the liturgy of
preparation and essentially
what the priest does is he ends up
um you know this is when he prepares the
bread and the wine
uh for the liturgy and on the discos or
the the patents um the little metal
plate on which
the bread is placed
there's the lamb which is the peace for
christ but then there are also uh
smaller pieces um and i know that i know
that this gets really specific and yes
you know who you are i know that some
people are gonna message me and say well
actually it's a it's a slightly
different commemoration in the byzantine
uh tradition versus the slavic tradition
i know that but just for simplicity's
sake
there's a particle for the mother of god
and then there are these nine smaller
particles for essentially nine ranks of
saints
um and so uh and and and most of the
saints in the orthodox church fall into
like one of those categories
um and that yeah that there's a little
bit of fluidity about like which which
rank is exactly what between various
traditions but
there there just seems to be the idea
that if you're gonna have a group of
holy people like this there needs to be
nine of them
um so what i thought we would do uh
is is take
take the our universal history series in
a direction which nobody has asked for
right everybody's like what are you
gonna do
ireland what are you guys doing america
what are you gonna do etc and i thought
we would just do something that nobody
has asked for at all
which is to talk about the nine worthies
and the reason that i wanted to do this
is because one of the
questions
um or another way to put this would be
like one of the realizations that i've
had while doing this series with you
and also discussing it with other people
is is just the way that these patterns
manifest themselves even outside of the
the the spaces that we have
kind of delineated as sacred and we
didn't start
specifically in sacred places like we
started with just like sort of like
secular medieval history when we started
the series but it very quickly moved
into talking especially when we get into
ethiopia and you have to really talk
about
um
all this stuff so in our in our previous
episode
an idea that i think really resonated
with a lot of people is we talked about
this idea that the saints uphold the
world and that this is both something
that we believe to be sort of literally
true
but also
that it it's a pattern which manifests
itself
in the lower regions of the mountain
right that
that even the
even the the p the people that you
venerate maybe not necessarily as as
holy
but definitely a sacred in some way like
a set apart in some way or you say
iconic
of a people group or of a city
those people that you you set aside for
veneration in some way
do really become the connective tissue
um you could say like love or veneration
is the connective tissue by which things
cohere yeah you could just use the word
commemorate is yes yeah you can
commemorate as good or weirded out by
the idea
that the people that you remember
through
uh through statute through naming things
you know obviously there's a hierarchy
of that but those are the people these
kind of they're an analogous to the idea
of the same to the just that uphold the
fabric of society through memory through
common connection through common
identification yeah in uh in his book
the ethics of beauty dr petitsa says um
uh talking about the the sort of
american love for veneration of the
american soldier uh which is something
you can actually do without necessarily
approving of
you know the various wars the soldiers
fought in right but that that if you go
to like arlington national seminar
cemetery for instance i almost hit
arlington national seminary um if you go
to arlington national cemetery or
there's also a national cemetery uh here
for veterans in in the place where i
live
not a single one of those soldiers
was killed for their country
they all gave their life for their
country
right and so this is a kind of it's a
different distinction uh it's it's uh so
so
um that that's a good example of
commemoration right um in in the united
states i don't know if you guys have
something like this up in
canadia land i mean
but but like you have something like it
but nothing like it at the same time
yeah we're not as uh as uh nationalistic
here yeah yeah in the united states when
a soul when a veteran dies even if you
know they just you know
were in the army when they were young
and then they they got out of the army
they had a normal life and they died in
old age there at the burial there will
be
like members of the military will show
up and there will be like a flag folding
ceremony and everything for that person
um these are all like kind of like lower
levels of commemoration
so when we talk about the nine worthies
uh the nine worthies are this group of
men and later on uh because in the
middle ages they're always like seeking
symmetry in things um later on there
becomes also a group of nine worthy
women
um to kind of parallel the nine worthy
men
uh but this is this is a list of people
and their their historical scriptural
legendary uh
men
not necessarily saints although you know
some of them like joshua in the bible is
obviously you know a saint
um in basically everybody's
church but
but they but they were selected for this
list
because they were seen to personify the
ideals of chivalry
which which people really wanted to
inculcate and this starts in
maybe you could say the the 12th and
1300s
uh which is when sh which is when the
idea of chivalry
is really starting to come into its own
we often think of a chivalry and the
chivalric romance as being like a
medieval thing
uh but it's actually it's actually kind
of a renaissance thing that was
projected back into the middle ages and
it's not to say there were not
chivalrous people in the middle ages
but it's but it's
uh
this is gonna sound funny to some people
but like go look it up that the
renaissance was a much more violent
period than the middle ages was
and
and um
and uh so there was this need
to sort of figure out what to do with
that
um
the problem of you know in in some in
some sense like societal problem number
one you're always trying to solve is
what i do with all my violent young men
right and that's that's like that's
really the main problem that most
societies are trying to deal with in
some way or other
and uh
and so what and so
this is where the this is where the
ideal of chivalry
um so i think the first the first list
uh was compiled in like 1312.
um so this is really where the idea of
chivalry starts to to be brought forward
uh based on older literature of course
things like the song of roland
uh and sir gowan and the green knight
and all the stuff which were much older
than yeah and just the arthur the
arthurian cycle the different arthurian
cycles the french cycles were already
there and so there were different
different cycles of and just aquitaine
in that whole kind of that whole world
of yeah
yeah yeah well and the the great thing
about like aquitaine is that you have
you have basically these these
troubadour kings who are like both
wandering minstrels but also
you know knights but also kings
and then you've got like eleanor whose
father was one of these troubador kings
and eleanor of aquitaine is you know
richard the lionheart's father and also
but also her mother rather but also the
mother of literally every other king in
europe at that at that time
and um and she was really into this
stuff and so it's like it's her
daughters
that become the patrons for like
christian detroit and and all these
other like the big arthurian
writers and so you it's it was a very
colorful time and a very colorful kind
of court there in aquitaine
so the nine worthies are um uh three
pagans
so these are hector of troy alexander
the great and julius caesar
three hebrews so joshua the son of nun
or jesus
in the greek
david
the king and then judah maccabee
and then three christians and the three
christian kings are king arthur
charlemagne
uh and godfrey abbouyon
um am i saying am i saying that right
yeah you're saying it pretty good hey
i'm pretty i'm i'm really pleased
um
because i'm so bad at french uh yeah so
godfrey of bouyon who most people maybe
have not heard of i think i think that's
the surprise on the list people are like
well i've heard of those other guys but
like who's does god forget
so
the reason that we're talking about this
in uh in universal history is to kind of
type two things together which is one
how does the how do these patterns
manifest themselves in what we would now
call secular spaces though perhaps they
would not have recognized
our that use of the word secular in the
1300s but like how did these things
manifest in secular spaces
um
uh because we have
these kinds of manifestations and we
have these kinds of
of heroes even now we've talked a lot
about lincoln and you know things like
this but also
um
that that uh
i mean i know that you're you're
sometimes a little down on superheroes
uh jonathan um i don't know if you mean
to come across that way or not um but
but uh obviously
obviously the whole world of like
superhero storytelling is a super mixed
bag yeah it's a super mixed bag uh
but also i think there is and i think
we're gonna have an essay about this in
uh in finding the golden key um
uh there is definitely a
let's say a longing for this kind of
commemoration which is which is
definitely manifesting itself in that
space right now
and so
when we find images of the nine worthies
there's a very early 13th century
carving which i think is the earliest
visual representation of them all
together
and it's in cologne and germany
uh but it's not
um they're
it's not in a church or in a sacred
place
it's in a city hall um and so the idea
is that you could say that these nine
men together represent
the ideal of
chivalry of kingship of lordship but
also they show the way in which
a secular order
um and and in the third in the 14th
century that that that really did mean
like the civil powers aside outside of
like the church powers right uh the way
that a secular order could also
participate in kind of this master
narrative this story of western
civilization that everybody was very
consciously trying to write themselves
into yeah
so um
uh there there are also um statues
there's a
uh there's a fountain in nuremberg
germany called the beautiful fountain
um and you can go out and look at some
pictures of these things online and i'm
sure we'll have them in the video for
um
uh which also shows the nine where these
and uh but but it's
at that same fountain there are like
these different groups of people right
and some of the groups are like apostles
saints martyrs etc and then over here in
this group you have the nine worthies
yeah
and um so it it uh it's a general
commemoration of yeah of different
aspects of reality let's say and the
political or the kind of civil sphere is
part yes yes and so basically what this
lets them do is they they're able to
bring in all of the the three strains
which basically constitute western
civilization which are
paganism and specifically greco-roman
paganism
uh
the our jewish inheritance
um that we have as as christians
and then uh and then the the the great
the great sort of icons of christian of
the christian ruler which for this
particular list
are king arthur charlemagne and godfrey
bouyon which for reasons we'll talk
about in a second you know it's funny
that there's no constantine
yeah there's some constantine there's no
justinian it's like it's definitely
western europe like yes it's definitely
definitely western europe yeah um uh so
for those of you who are who have been
hankering for like some more western
europe stuff this is this is your day so
i thought what we could do is is very
quickly talk about each one of the
worthies yeah and why they're included
and i think there's a lot there are a
lot of people out there who will be
interested in going out and reading uh
more of these people
um there's definitely a um
something that i've heard over and over
again recently has been
uh
like it's really a cry or a hunger
uh especially from like a lot of young
men who are into the symbolic world and
other things like that for
you know
trying to trying to like navigate like
what does it look like to be a man
what's it look like to be
masculine um
that's a really difficult thing to do
right now it seems like we're we're
constantly like falling into one error
or or the other yeah but this is a
question that they're really concerned
with in the middle ages too it was like
one of the dominant questions
of let's say medieval legends and
fiction yeah and
i'm curious about some of the choices
myself rather than others and so are
there sources that kind of explain why
or there are okay yeah so i'm gonna be
reading from um uh just a text um
it doesn't have a helpful name uh
in english it's the history of the nine
worthies of the world three whereof were
gentiles
uh
and then it lists all the gentiles three
jews three christians being an account
of their glorious lives worthy actions
renowned victories and deaths um okay so
that's actually a super helpful name
it's just very long i put that on a book
jacket yeah yeah yeah yeah put that i
mean people did back then and this
particular book uh was made as an it's
an it's an older book but it was made as
kind of like an english translation in
like the 1600s like the 1630s so that's
that's actually i mean it kind of shows
how long and how late even into the
modern period this idea of the nine
worthies were and i would just say do
you do you guys have a phrase uh dressed
to the nines
uh yeah i i never understood that yeah
so that's a reference to that's a
reference to to this
comes from a shakespeare play but it's a
it's a reference to it's a reference to
the nine worthies in other words um and
there was actually a king of france
francis the first of france who would
dress up like one of the nine wordies
um and so he was literally like on
different occasions yeah yeah
yeah and like like in the in the and
this is during the renaissance he would
dress in what was called the antique
mode in other words like like
like with the roman toga and everything
yeah or or like or like you know an
armor yeah in armor and things like this
and he would like walk around like this
to like kind of consciously associate
himself with the nine worthies actually
most of our most of our illustrations of
the nine worthies come from a kind of
book called an armorial which is a book
of heraldry and it's a it's a book
intended to like teach you heraldry and
like keep track of of
who in the kingdom has these different
signs so if you see this heraldic device
you'll be able to recognize that this is
an important part of your education
as a as a nobleman
and uh but the first several pages
usually the first ten pages of a of an
armorial these are custom-made books for
very wealthy people so the first ten
pages of an armorial would be
the nine worthies and then the tenth
page
would be
whoever commissioned the book
okay you know and and and and dressed up
also like the nine worthies and so so
the i yeah so the idea connecting it all
together yeah you're you're and it
became this very personal way
for people
obviously people of a certain social
status but it became a very personal way
for people to connect themselves into
the larger story uh you could say a
western uh chivalry
of of
let's say the proper use of secular
power yeah yeah so it's interesting but
it's important also to mention it's
something that i keep repeating probably
at every podcast which is that even
though
the tradition kind of appears later than
the middle ages in order for people to
have recognized these these people as
the nine worthies it means that this was
something which was already
kind of uh let's say bubbling up in
culture there was something that people
when they saw it they said yes of course
these are the nine worthies if it hadn't
been
if it hadn't been something that people
could recognize you know then it
wouldn't have lasted and it wouldn't
have been perpetuated right
well and so so to that i want to say two
things one is it's one of the most
irritating things in the world to me
when somebody says something like
oh well
the title theotokos
was not approved until the council of
ephesus
and therefore the veneration of the
mother of god began like on that date
like
that's not how things work that does not
know anything that's not how anything
works like
so just as a good rule of thumb if you
come across something and it says like
the first mention in a text that we have
of this particular thing is this date
what you need to do is back up
one to 200 years
at a minimum yeah before that date and
set like and just like
assume this has been in the error long
enough for somebody to write this down
so like the the the most
the most recent um so if this list was
first coined in the early 1300s the most
recent person on the list is godfrey
bouyon who died in
1100
so he's
not quite a contemporary but
but he's really close so obviously there
couldn't have been a list
like this before he died
but this concept
um let's we could just say like this is
the ultimate like the uh the
crystallization of this concept which
had been part of
a part of western europe for a long long
time so you can you know that for
example charlemagne
consciously modeled himself after joshua
and king david right so you can
understand how and constantine right so
so you can understand how this is
something like you like we said that's
already in the culture and now is is
bubbling up and manifesting itself
concretely right so let's go let's let's
start let's go because i have some
questions myself about some of these
were these okay so first guy on the list
hector of troy
uh which i think most people uh who are
listening this podcast will be uh
familiar with the iliad
and the story of hector uh
which means that everything you think
you know about hector is pro is sort of
wrong
um in the in the west until a very late
date
they did not have access to
the homeric poems in their originals and
so what they had to go off of was mostly
things like virgil and other authors who
were basically retelling the story in
latin or in some other western language
and telling it especially from the
trojan perspective which is important to
understand the romans saw themselves as
trojans and so
their vision of the trojans were they
were the noble ones right more noble
let's say than the greeks and the
trojans
yeah so this is a really this is a
really big point and and this goes all
the way back to video number one that we
did in the series right is that the
romans saw themselves as trojans
right and and therefore the the uh
portrayal that we get
of the trojans in the aeneid is
extremely
more like light so that the thing about
the iliad is that it's actually so
balanced there are no
there's no good guys or bad guys in the
iliad i mean into their individual
people but the two sides they're not
you know uh it's it's uh
it is a truly great work of art in that
it is written with just deep sympathy
for the human beings on both sides of
this conference is very complex work um
the hector even in the iliad hector is
shown
he's the best yeah he's the best dude in
in the iliad as well uh so in in the in
the legend that they had received and
that gets told retold in the stories of
the nine worthies and all the way up to
the time of shakespeare okay when
shakespeare uh writes about the
his poem his his play about the the fall
of troy and troilus and christina
um
[Music]
hector is
he he's so great achilles can't kill him
in a fair fight
uh and so there are different variations
of this but um for instance in this this
particular work on the nine worthies
um
uh of course they're all they're all
knights so they're all jousting
right so like take that image that you
have of like
you know hoplites and armor or like brad
pitt or whatever and put that out of
your head and imagine just like full-on
heraldic devices guys on horses jousting
in front of the gates of troy that's how
that's how they they portrayed it you
know
and um
and uh so so there are several times
during the conflict that hector unseats
achilles
but is not willing to kill him
because it's not fair he's not gonna
he's not gonna kill a downed opponent
and so then finally um in this
particular telling
when uh when
uh achilles finally decides like that
the greek leaders tell achilles okay you
have to kill hector
you have to go out and kill him achilles
comes out and uh and uh at a at a
particular time we're told that hector
is actually bearing up the body of one
of the greek princes who had died to
bury him in honor so hector is just like
here's a worthy opponent i'm going to
carry his body
and have it buried in state
and at that point achilles runs up and
kills him when his back is turned so
it's it's a really despicable kind of
treasonous way um and actually a lot of
the
all three of the pagan worthies
in in this
in this telling die uh
due to treason right julie caesar's dad
uh alexander is poisoned by his generals
and uh so
so hector the thing that makes hector uh
a worthy is is his great valor in combat
um which is this is gonna
some people are gonna be like yeah great
valor in combat and some other people
listening this are gonna be like
oh i don't know about
you know and you know and there is
definitely one could say
a strong pacifist
uh inclination within traditional
christianity
um
things that christ says the example that
we have of many saints
there is also
however
a a strong uh
say vindication of like the proper uses
of violence within the tradition yeah
chivalry ends up being something like a
coded version of right you know the
honorable way to fight if you have to
and the honorable way to kind of deal
with aggression if you need to right
yeah and so that's yeah and and it
basically becomes a
it basically becomes what the peace of
god in the middle ages was on a national
level chivalry becomes on a personal
level so the idea of the peace of god is
that there would be rules governing
warfare you could only do things in
certain ways you could only fight on
certain days you know certain holy days
and things like that were not days that
was appropriate to campaign on and and
for the most part during the middle ages
people
kept to this yeah and this is in western
europe um and for the most part people
people really stuck to this
um and so you you have a lot of wars in
the middle ages but the wars by modern
standards would just be like very small
border skirmishes you know it's not
until until
uh the rise of secularism that we're
able to just really kill each other in
efficient ways and just like in mass
um
but uh so so there's there's definitely
a there's definitely a uh
uh let's say on a personal level
chivalry is is
um you know a certain thing so part of
the code of chivalry this comes up in
uh christian's uh
uh percival uh part of the code of
chivalry is there are certain days on
which one does not bear arms uh for
instance on holy friday
um is a day it just would not be
appropriate to wear armor to carry a
sword etc and things like this
so so there's so yeah it's um so the
things that make hector one of the
worthies and really the first worthy
because everything kind of begins at
troy that's where that's definitely
the trojan war uh the trojan war is
definitely
where the west was born yeah
and uh and hector is sort of the great
hero of that war from a medieval
perspective
and hector and so hector is is uh he's
really good at fighting but he also
shows mercy and love towards his
his opponents and he's not willing to
kind of take advantage of somebody in an
unfair way yeah and you can see that in
the story in the original story the idea
of achilles you know misusing the body
of hector after he died is kind of a
counter example to the way in which the
medievals would perceive the knightly
way of fighting and of treating your
enemy right
right and so i i think i think that
actually that
there's like an exact
twist there right from the way that
hector dies in the story which is he
dies because he's honoring the body of
his foe yeah exactly versus the way that
achilles treats his body in the iliad um
so that's kind of nice so yeah so hector
is great and by the way hector is i mean
like i'm i'm just a massive hector
fanboy like i should just like put that
out now um he's one of my favorite
i don't know what you could say
legendary figures historical figures
whatever um people go back and forth on
whether the trojan war was actually
historical and i think actually the
current thing is that actually it is
historical but people have been going
back and forth on whether it was
historical since like the time of few
cities yeah
um but what everybody has agreed on is
that whether or not it was like a
historical thing it was it's super
important and it's it's kind of it's
kind of the first the first story in the
west yeah so the second worthy which
will be no surprise to you is alexander
the great of course alexander the great
is um
uh i think nowadays he would definitely
be hashtag canceled he's uh he's got a
lot of shall we say problematic things
about his life
uh the way that he uh we're told um
[Music]
uh
i mean there's there's a ton of wild
stuff in this particular retelling of
alexander um and definitely
his his uh sexual mores
um are are not christian um not even the
way like hectors were like hector hector
despite not being a christian is you
know faithful to his to his wife femme
man characters children there's and
there's definitely a very long tradition
that that at some point helen kind of
like threw herself at hector and he was
like no thanks yeah i don't i don't need
this crazy in my life you know um uh but
he's also the only person in troy in the
in the iliad he's basically the only
person in troy who actually treats her
decently
yeah and so she weeps for him at his
death um anyway i just really love
hector a lot if that's not right so
alexander but this is the retelling in
the nine worthies
yeah yeah yeah this is the retelling and
so this is the thing like when there are
faults in these guys lives
they don't shy away from from telling
those things right
and this is
i mean this is a thing like we're
so and we're just such babies now
jonathan like we're i mean we really are
though like we're just giant babies like
if there is
if there's a person whose life is worthy
and and worthy of emulation
in a lot of different ways but then they
have like one thing wrong with them yeah
we're like well sorry that person's
problematic and and like
i don't care if it's the right or the
left like yeah this is this is just in
the air right now we're just
we're so fragile yeah
and uh and so they're setting up
alexander as kind of the
the uh in the medieval perspective you
could say he he's the
you know if hector is the first knight
alexander is the first emperor
right and and of course everyone agrees
that you should have an emperor
and everyone agrees that whoever the
emperor is should be kind of the best
and most worthy person
and so even though
even though uh alexander has a lot of
um he has a lot of faults he's portrayed
in the in this retelling as being
uh
you know he loses his temper and and
kills somebody who's really close to him
but then after that
he
he shows so much remorse
that he like starves himself and they
eventually have to like force him to
start eating again so it's kind of like
it's not saying it's okay that he did
that thing but also like
he did demonstrate repentance a lot but
after afterwards and though the way that
it's sort of portrayed is that is that
alexander is this
i mean he's like this really dynamic
young genius uh which he was
um
and that but that he had he had sort of
the wrong people around him yeah which
is not saying it like wasn't his fault
but we're told you know he's he has uh
you know um
he had this influence from this
particular
greek philosopher not aristotle in this
case uh but one of the people who is one
of aristotle's students um uh who who
basically told him
well you should be you know look at all
your achievements you should be
worshipped as a god right alexander
being very young
you know having this mentor tell him you
should be worshipped as a god said oh i
get i guess i should be worshipped as
god but then we're told but the
macedonian soldiers
would have none of it and just continue
to salute him as their general and he
was also fine with that yeah and so
um
uh there's some fun stuff in here one uh
thing that's in here is uh when he
conquers india
um he's seduced by the indian queen
uh whose name was cleophys not cleopatra
uh cleophas um
and but but she does a very cleopatra
thing which is she
she basically buys her kingdom back
with you know by seducing alexander um
and then has a son from him whom she
names alexander and of course eventually
you know cleopatra seduces julius caesar
and then they have a son that they name
julius caesar yeah and uh but the the
i mean this is a real symbolism happens
moment because cleophys is a i mean
she's a real historical figure like
there's no ambiguity about about it the
ambiguity would be around
like who her son who her son's father
actually was yeah um and and the way
that like the greco-roman chroniclers
would write about it is they would say
um
they would say that oh she had a son
named alexander
whoever her father whoever his family
might have been might have been yeah
wink wink
um
uh but of course you know it's it's
significant she's the she's the queen of
india in this particular telling which
is we've talked about the overlap
between india and ethiopia and you know
and as the steeler of the heart and all
that so you have all those things going
on in the story what makes alexander
great
um
lots and lots of things i mean uh he he
defeats his enemies but he's really fair
to everyone he conquers
that that comes out uh over and over
again
um and uh he
um
uh so he has he has a bunch of faults
but also he's at the end of the day like
he's he's great because of because of
his accomplishments and because because
of his
uh the the let's say the just way that
he treated the people that whom he
defeated right so that in so you have
this idea that you should be in victory
you should be
uh you should be
moderate and subdued in the way that you
uh again unlike us like we're such
like we're like just little toddlers
even like on the internet as soon as
somebody scores a point against somebody
else you know they just like they're
ready to dance on the grave you know
and uh and and
the the medieval idea of chivalry is
that is that you really you should you
should be able to win your fights
but also when you win you've got to be
gracious um and i will just say one last
thing which is
they were not
uh inattentive to the fact that
alexander died at the age of 33
which is a which is of course
also the age that christ died
at um and they a lot of people seem to
have noticed this and
commented on it in various ways uh
there there's a lot of stuff in this
particular retelling that is missing
uh
there's no gates of alexander there's no
griffin chariot anything's like and and
for the most part all of these
tellings are very grounded you could say
um there is not a whole lot of
what we consider to be like mythical
yeah material that's actually in them um
they're they're they're pretty grounded
all right so third guy on the list is of
course julius caesar i don't think i
need to introduce caesar to anyone um
and basically everything you know or
heard about caesar is isn't is in this
retelling um
why is caesar included uh he's included
because he's he becomes this sort of
um
this model of
of kingship and nowadays like we're use
we're we're conditioned to think of
caesar as kind of a bad guy yeah i was
going to say like yeah caesar not
augustine yeah
yeah so so we're we're conditioned to
kind of see caesar as as kind of a bad
guy because of his
uh because because like he he sort of
like brought about the end of the
republic right yeah and also because he
he was such a ruthless conqueror like
yes
you know this idea that he killed a
million
yeah but the answer the answer is is
dante um uh sees and dante's not the
reason but dante just like as part of
his whole world they saw julius caesar
as being the
uh
as being sort of the the
the first manifestation you could say of
the ideal roman man or or the ideal
roman emperor yeah right
and so uh
well like scipio africanus is the first
ideal roman man but then caesar's the
first ideal roman emperor
and um and so the idea was that that
caesar was setting up
a uh
he was setting up like a perfect reign
um and and basically he had subdued the
world he was going to bring peace to the
world
um and again
caesar shows great clemency to his
enemies who aren't gauls
and and
i'm from france i am allowed to lie i
know i know i know i know no but but
like when he defeats like pompey's army
and people like this like he's he shows
he shows great clemency to them
um but also but also like he doesn't put
up with traitors he doesn't put up with
you know people trying to go behind him
things like this um ironically i guess
because that's how he dies yeah but um
but in the in the end
in the end um so in in the lowest region
of hell in the inferno
right one of the three people who's in
prison there
you know you have three famous traitors
and one of them is brutus
right you know and so and so uh for
dante
the worst possible sin that you could
commit
would be not just treachery
but treachery against your lord yeah and
so in the structure of hell you have
like hell is all these sort of nested
descending circles but then the final
the final tier in hell of circles is a
city
right and so the point is that these are
the crimes that cause like these other
things are like
animal passions
but these are the crimes that cause
human civilization to cease to cohere as
dante saw happening in florence and he
saw happening in italy around him at
that particular time
and so what's the thing at the end of
the day that most does that will it's
assassinating your
what they would have considered to be
like your lawful ruler right um that
that's the thing that's going to cause
society to cease to cohere yeah yeah so
so julius caesar is is on here and um
i'll just say
um
each one of these begins with like a
little poem
um
and so we're told great julius caesar
next attained the name of the third
worthy whose immortal fame remains still
fresh in records of time
he to the empire of the world did climb
and what he conquered by his sword and
fight he with his pen did elegantly
right this is not great poetry but
at length through many wounds his soul
hence fled and he who never before was
conquered in war he who was slaughtered
strewed so many lands with his own blood
and brood the seat of wronged justice
and fell down
a sacrifice to appease the incensed gown
so there's this there's definitely this
idea of
of caesar being a
uh let's say a precursor of christ
and that he was a sacrifice that was
necessary for the public peace
right and so then like the gospel of
saint john
uh it says you know they say it is
necessary that one man should die for
his nation right
and that's that's how they sort of saw
what happened to caesar as it's sort of
like it's regrettable
that caesar had to be killed it's
regardable that he regrettable that he
kind of grasped for power too quickly
but at the end of the day he becomes
sort of a martyr to the peace of the
roman empire and it's because of that i
mean it makes a note in here to say not
a single one of the people who
assassinated caesar
lived
outlived him by more than two years yeah
you know like all of those people
and it's really the death of caesar at
least in this in this particular telling
it's the death of caesar that galvanizes
the roman people and makes the rise of
augustus a thing that's actually
possible yeah basically from that point
forward
the the people at large can't conceive
of
of of going back to the older way of
doing things
okay so that's caesar
uh move on to joshua um
everything in the in the story about
joshua is just exactly what's in the
bible um so i'm gonna assume people
either have a familiarity with that if
they don't um there are lots of bibles
out there so go buy one just go i don't
know what to say
like the book of joshua is super super
awesome but i will say this um
uh
this is how his story begins it says who
can see the sun and not remember joshua
and the great commerce that this
valorous captain had with the king of
stars
which is just i mean that's a the king
of stars is god in this case right you
know making the sun stand still yeah
yeah yeah and the the host you know the
starry host the host of heavens kind of
like fighting on the side of joshua yeah
all the world lift their eyes up to it
that is the sun but none hath
but none he hath lifted up his voice so
far as it to make himself be heard and
obeyed the stars knew joshua or jesus
because he bore the name of him that
formed them
it is he that gave us the foretaste of
the name jesus at which the heaven the
earth and hell to bend the knee so um
and i and it goes on to talk there's a
really lengthy and actually quite
beautiful digression at the beginning of
this talking about
so i think sometimes like especially if
you came from like an evangelical
background we read joshua as sort of
like the the kind of lesser sequel to
moses like moses is really great and
then josh was kind of uh and then after
joshua dies everything just goes to hell
yeah right but uh literally um
but joshua was not seen that way uh in
the early christian communities and even
even now in the orthodox church or
uh in in these medieval stories
um so you have this you have this uh
uh this sort of play on words in the
gospel according to saint john in
chapter one
it says the law came uh by moses but
grace and truth came by jesus christ
right so um and of course so so it
that's a play in words because of course
jesus in greek is is joshua right that's
the name of moses successor
right and so uh and so so joshua was the
one who's actually able to enter the
promised land he's the one that's able
to perform everything that god said and
before him yeah and and conquer the
enemies of god et cetera right and so
and so he fulfills the promise right
it's not moses who fulfills the promise
right exactly yeah and so john chapter
one is like riffing on that a little bit
and sort of saying you know
jesus right he's the fulfillment of
of the promise so you've got joshua um
who is uh he was great we're told
because uh he's so much worthier than
the three before him because they
worship false gods but he worshipped the
true god by whose power he caused the
sun and moon to stand still so yeah
pretty cool stuff uh number five on the
list and the exact middle point in the
list is david
and again there's nothing surprising in
in the david thing like it's just all
the stuff that's in the bible
peop uh
people should read the life of david
like a lot i think uh because because be
frightened if they do it but it's got
everything it's just got everything in
it though yeah i know but it's it's hard
to see for a lot of people like how
how much of these these these
approximations of jesus story are in the
story of david because they often
they often are twisted like they don't
look exactly the same or they kind of
failed you could say almost like right
kind of failed versions of jesus almost
right right so you've got david
number and then the third hebrew in the
list is judas maccabeeus
now people are
probably a little less familiar with him
than they are with joshua and david
but he's the he's the sort of the bic
the big leader of the maccabean revolt
this is actually also in the bible if
you have the director's cut version of
the bible
um
yeah um
uh
i'm not gonna go too much into the the
whole story of judah maccabees just for
the sake of time but it's good you could
say that he's the last glorious moment
of of kind of
jewish kingship before and also but also
like the uh
the
the accidental opening of the door to
rome
right the maccabees make this alliance
with rome
and so later when pompey the great shows
up with an army at jerusalem he's like
well we have a legal document you guys
said we could do this kind of a thing um
and that's that's i mean that's that's a
historical fact but it's also in it's
also in this legend okay again again
the christians who put this list
together
still had maccabees
in their bible of course so everything
that's in the legend like again there's
nothing surprising if you read first and
second maccabees you already know all
this all this stuff
why is he in the list okay joshua that's
easy david super easy to figure out why
david is in the list um david is also
the great example of somebody who would
be just totally hashtag canceled um you
know like he's
he's just i mean david is just like he's
he's he's literally all over the place
yeah he's just he's so crazy
um
but um
and there's like very frank discussion
in in his legend here about you know the
whole bathsheba thing yeah and what goes
on there and the way that
the way that all of the bad stuff that
eventually happens to david family
david's family kind of goes back to that
and in spite of all of that okay i will
say one thing so this is cool
um do you know
uh
i'm sure you remember when david gets
the idea that he he wants to build the
temple and he says it's it's it's
shameful
that
the ark of god should dwell in tents
i i live in a palace right
so something that his legend kind of
points out which i never noticed before
but it's totally just in the bible okay
is that that is an exact
almost word for word parallel to what
uriah says when david
tells him to come home
when david orders him home to like cover
up the fact that bathsheba is pregnant
yeah
uriah says
it would be shameful for me
to dwell in
a house while joab and the ark of god
are dwelling in tents really
it's the same
thing
huh like and i don't know what to do
with that it's like an opposite it's
like it's like yeah it's reversed yeah
yeah like i didn't even like i i just
discovered that like literally this week
i was today years old
when when i read that and i was like
so yeah yeah i mean we have to think
about it before yeah
what it can mean but for sure it's it's
clearly a reference they're referencing
each other yeah and and i mean again
like that's that's just in the bible but
the the guy that was putting these
legends together notice kind of knows
the parallels there so that's okay
that's cool um so judah maccabees um
why is he included um he's included
mainly because
he was a very successful um
military commander
he was never
his big thing the big thing that the
maccabees are kind of known for
is that they were they were willing to
die for to defend god's truth and and
the law of the law of god yeah um and of
course and the the
the whole story of the maccabees is very
important to us it's an early
exemplar of the idea of the veneration
of the saints
in second temple judaism and all this
different stuff
and so judah and of course judah dies
the way that a knight should die which
is in battle right so he goes he kind of
goes out fighting and we're told
what are the things that make him great
um
he uh
the people wept and made a great
limitation for the death of of a
commander so valiant for whatsoever
virtue hath of great whatsoever valor
hath of generous
met in the person of judah maccabeeus to
make a marvel of his life and give a
mortal memory to his name in the space
of six years he sustained the great and
prodigious forces of three kings of asia
as you have heard opposing himself with
a little flying camp in other words like
a little guerrilla force yeah against
armies of 40 60 and 100 000 men which he
put into disorder and confusion he
defeated nine generals of the infidels
in ranged battles and combats killing
some with his own hands carrying away
their spoils so that all of his great
qualities valor always held the upper
rank and worthily entitled him to the
name of worthy so in the list he's
actually the one who's most known for
valor all right um so he's the third jew
in the list and then we get to the three
christians the first one is arthur
everyone has heard of king arthur i
think um
i'm interested to say why they think
arthur because there's something about
arthur there's an ambiguity about arthur
right right so
in this particular retelling
uh a lot of the
later stuff
like you know having an incestuous son
with his sister and things like this
is it's not there
we'll say like it exists in certain like
tellings but there but but they hadn't
come to dominate
at this particular point in history
um it's not really
in the english language it's really when
uh when mallory does his retelling based
on the french book yeah um uh that that
we sort of like accept all of these
pieces as sort of like being set in
stone one could say i did a little
arthurian pun there like set in stone
anyway um
and so in this legend it's mostly about
him yeah and it's written and it's it's
uniting bitten britain fighting off the
pagan saxons
and then also bullying the uh the roman
legates who came to collect tribute from
him um
so
uh i'll i'll just say this at the
beginning uh because this is like this
is just like
you know when when people listen to or
when people listen to these series and
they they ask questions like well did x
really happen or whatever he's
introduced uh with saying
um
the british writers have related such
strange and miraculous actions and
adventures of this worthy prince that
many intelligent men have been apt to
think that all which have been written
of his heroic deeds is mere fiction and
invention
yey some are of the opinion
that there never was any such person but
though historians disagree about times
and places some writing carelessly and
others superstitiously all those
superstitious historians out there yet
they all agree upon the predecessors and
successors of this noble king
but as it is mostly but as it is most
uh
awful infidelity to doubt that there was
a joshua it is a wicked atheism to
question if there were a david and
totally unreasonable to deny the being
of judah maccabees it may be judged
folly to affirm that there was never any
alexander jewish seizure seizure caesar
godfrey the julius caesar that's a
that's a bad julius caesar yeah
um or charlemagne so we may be thought
guilty of incredulity and ingratitude to
deny or doubt the honorable acts of our
victorious arthur
and uh this is the premise this is
premise and vindication of our hero and
his immortal name and fame whereby he
justly gained the title of the seventh
worthy of the world and now on to his
history so it gets into his history but
there is like a little kind of an
argument at the beginning for like
whether he exists or not yeah yeah his
inclusion on the list because he is this
he is this like you could say like a
lodestone that attracts all these
different legends and things like this
and actually most of the arthurian
legends aren't about arthur they're
about the people in his court and it
actually talks about that it says
there are 12
you know like like he has he has as nice
at the round table and if arthur wasn't
so great then surely one of those guys
would be in this list
but arthur eclipses all of them for
his acts of chivalry which is actually
also i mean that's that's in the other
like the more popular arthurian material
as well the thing that makes arthur
great
um i think is is the fact that a he is
he's just like the perfect
uh embodiment of all the chivalric
legends right and all of the other
knights had these different fatal flaws
um in to some degree or other but it's
not until much later that arthur is also
given one of those yeah and basically
once once arthur isn't the perfect
knight anymore that's when they have to
bring on along like galahad so um
uh we have arthur then we have
charlemagne yeah so we have arthur then
we have charlemagne charlemagne is the
great
christian
king
right he's he's in this list mainly
because he defeated saracen armies and
forced lots and lots of people to
convert to christianity um and of course
maybe the circus did they say that in
the the thing that he couldn't that he
forced well what it says what it says is
that um he overcame all of his enemies
he was crowned emperor of rome
and the christian faith he always
defended against saracens he contended
against the huns and the pagans he he
too conquered
um
and yet all of his fury he laid by
if they would idols leave and the true
god obey oh okay yeah yeah so yeah and
of course enforce somebody it's like
it's like if you convert then my sword
will fall lightly yeah right exactly
yeah
freaky drinky huh charlemagne is is the
the the guy in here that in in
once is like makes the most sense to me
like he's he's but he's the origin of
western europe right the understanding
of western europe the way we understand
it is right found in the story of
charlemagne and the frankish the
frankish king [ __ ]
yes
but also like there are a lot of you
know from an orthodox perspective like
we're a little
yeah little frosty on charlemagne yeah
because he's also he's also the
beginning of the schism even though it's
way before the schism well there's also
like a hint at what's coming in his
court and his theologians and the way he
sees himself as emperor you know in in
competition with the with the byzantines
when charlemagne was coronated he
actually set off to
constantinople to have a sakos asakos
made like the like the tunic the thing
our bishops were now
he sent off to have one of those made
for him to wear at his coronation and it
was a very deliberate attempt
to
identify himself as sort of like the
the legitimate yeah this is something
people need to understand from
charlemagne we'll get it when we talk
about it more but he didn't see himself
as emperor of the west the way a lot of
people tried to portray it he saw
himself as the roman emperor as the
emperor as the one that succeeded
irene's husband it's like irene is crazy
and now we need a new emperor so he's
the emperor so he he saw themselves as
just the emperor
stop just stop there like there you
didn't right right
yeah
yes so
um
yeah but uh there's there's a i mean
there there is a whole thing i'll just
read this bit
the false synod of the greeks
untruly called the seventh this is
talking about the seventh ecumenical
council whoa
um
was condemned and rejected by all of the
bishops who who subscribed to the
condemnation and this is but this is
like this is a historical fact this is
right court theologians rejected the
seventh ecumenical council and then
later the pope had to basically
tell him to back down steamroll through
and try to get it accepted but they
mentioned this in the story yeah this is
in the story so the seventh ecumenical
council is the false synod false synod
of the greeks right yes yeah yeah so
i mean this is why pope benedict says
that the west never fully accepted the
seventh medical council because it's
just
you see it much later you know you see
it in these texts where it comes up
again that it's like this council we
don't like it even right
and there's there's uh you know
especially talking now and you know
everybody's you know much friendlier and
chummy these days
um
which i guess is good it's nice that
nobody's trying to burn me at a stake
but
um but also like you know
people will say well you know the roman
roman catholic theology around the icon
and the orthodox the the exact same
thing
historically that has not been true it
might be might be true now sure um you
know i'm but but historically that
that's not been the case um even in the
west
even as they had they they obviously did
have images but they would have looked
at the the ways that we use the we use
icons liturgically yeah um because
because we don't just like hang up some
nice pictures or what you know but
there's there are particular times the
liturgy the priest kisses this icon the
priest kisses you know this other icon
and things like this and they they did
look at those things especially at the
time of charlemagne they didn't look at
those things as as idolatrous that's
problematic yeah and they and the west
never took up the incarnational argument
for icons and like the final proof of
that is that when calvin criticizes
images he doesn't even use he doesn't
even address that argument right he
doesn't even he doesn't even address the
main argument of the seventh ecumenical
concept because he doesn't
know it doesn't know is yeah doesn't
know it yeah
um so why is he in this list um you know
from the west from a western christian
perspective it's pretty obvious why is
the list i will say
um he he was seen
um he was seen as like this defender of
the faith both against the false synod
of the greeks as well as against the
saracens or you know the muslim armies
invading europe
um and but also for the west he was seen
as a restorer of knowledge or restore of
education you know bringing the monks in
transcriptions
there was a sense in which he was like
an enlightener of
western europe so all that stuff is in
here we're told that at the when he was
68 years old
um that he uh spent three years you know
the last few years of his life
cloistered away reading the bible
and the books of saint augustine it says
whom he admired above all the doctors of
the church so ortho bros just go wild
with that
and um
and he resided at uh paris had frequent
conference with the learned and he there
he erected a famous university of course
paris is where the university is kind of
like
you know at least one particular
university model is kind of birthed yeah
right and so this legend consciously
tries to connect charlemagne back to
that
and yeah and getting into a western
scholarship is right basically in
charlemagne yeah right yeah
so uh and then the final person on this
list who people probably most mysterious
familiar with is godfreya bouyon
who
who were said who were told was called
the king of jerusalem now we don't say
he is the king of jerusalem we say he
was called the king of jerusalem
interesting so godfrey beyond uh just
like the high level version of the story
is that he was
one of the leaders of the first crusade
which was kind of the most successful of
the crusades
he uh he retook
jerusalem
and then died a year or two after uh
retaking jerusalem
and he he was he was the ruler of
jerusalem after it was retaken
um
but he refused the title of the king of
jerusalem and i think this is this is
he's on this list for a few reasons one
is like within 10 or 20 years of his
death there are already legends about
him you know like fighting bears and
decapitating camels with a single stroke
of his sword and actually a bunch of the
same kind of legends that get attributed
to richard the lionheart who's another
famous creator
um obviously i was a big rejected
lionheart fan as a kid for you know
obvious reasons yeah um you know uh but
uh
uh
there almost immediately after his death
like he became
you could say that he became people
considered him to be the apex
of the christian knight like like all of
these things had been setting up to that
and then he was like the perfect example
of what it looked like in practice
right so he was somebody with that was
within like kind of living memory when
these lists started to be putting being
put together and somebody that you could
look at like and very consciously say
he's
he's one of the like he was the greatest
night of his day uh when he was
when he conquered jerusalem and he was
set up to rule it
um he was presented with a crown that's
like really richly adorned with pearls
and all these different things
and he refused it and he said why would
i bear the name of a king in a place
where my savior
was crowned with reproaches
why would i take a scepter in my hand
where he took a cross upon his shoulders
why would i suffer a crown of gold upon
my head where he received a crown of
thorns
so he refused the title of king and i
think this is a thing at the end of the
day that makes him worthy of inclusion
on this list was not just his valor in
battle but but at the end of the day his
his uh his unwillingness to seize power
yeah there's an interesting parallel
also even in this image of the last
roman emperor i mean actually there's no
relationship well yes no you think there
is uh well i don't know that there's a
relation but but it's but it's the same
pattern yeah the idea of like the last
emperor or the the ultimate emperor
basically giving his crown up to christ
in jerusalem yeah in jerusalem in
jerusalem yeah where else would this
happen so he uh he he only rules
jerusalem for a couple of years and he
dies in the year 1100 and a couple of
years later and then his brother baldwin
uh takes but baldwin takes the title
king of jerusalem like he he he accepts
the crown uh but but godfrey didn't and
godfrey's on this list and baldwin isn't
so here you go so there you go yeah but
it's interesting to see like you said
that the last worthy
uh has this this kind of rendering up of
of uh civil power up to
a higher state or up to god you know so
it's like we celebrate all this civil
power but we end with something which
recognizes that it it's obviously in a
certain manner there's a vanity to it
and the one we we recognize the most is
the one that kind of gave it up to god
and so i think i think uh yeah he's sort
of the plenitude of the whole list right
at the at the end of the at the end of
the day
this list is not to say
you know hey you secular rule ruler you
should be charlemagne
you know you should be like charlemagne
in certain respects you should defend
the church and you should descend the
other thing it's not saying you should
be
you know judah maccabees though you
should be like in certain respects but
the very last person in the list is
godfrey
and godfrey
does all of these things but then he
refuses the crown he says christ is the
only real king of jerusalem
and
and the where these are
i mean uh they're all over monuments
civic buildings fountains things like
that in these public secular spaces
um they're also
a major genre of let's say of uh drama
in the middle ages and even into the
renaissance like this is there there are
you know plays within plays in
shakespeare's plays
that are masks you know m-a-s-q-e
q-u-e
there are masks or plays
uh about the lives of the various
nine-worthy's so these guys were in in
some sense like sort of superheroes yeah
right that they were like historical
kind of a little contemporary you know
hector's on a night on a horse with a
with a lance you know yeah um so they're
historical they're kind of contemporary
but they're also a little bit legendary
uh
and but but they sort of they sort of
like
caught up the whole ideal of
uh into themselves of what did it look
like
in western europe
to be
uh to be a noble to be
to be chivalrous to be uh
to be worthy in other words still like
have
to have
what does it look like when the virtues
manifest themselves
in a person who is maybe not exactly a
saint
but he is
but is still like worthy it's worthy and
it's interesting because in different
from hagiography where in hagiography
there would just be this kind of
celebration of the saint almost without
reserve right in these texts and in
these celebrations you find the reserve
as part of the way that they're
remembered that exactly here they are
remembered for these virtues but we also
acknowledge these uh these problems that
they had and these faults so so it's a
it's a balanced tradition
so and of course by by having these
three triads like
going back to the beginning of the video
it had to be nine why did it have to be
nine because you need
uh
like for this this this picture of
chivalry
to be something that
can uh
that that really has legs and is really
part of this coherent picture in this
vision of the world that they possess in
the middle ages
you had to you you've got to you've got
to have all three pieces you've got to
have your greeks in romans you've got to
have your the you know the jewish
inheritance and you've got to have the
christians uh culminating in this
example of this
of this christian who actually kind of
goes all the way back to the start right
he goes east
um
uh actually it mentions that uh and i
don't know if this is something that
happened historically or not but it
mentions that he was like at one point
on his way to constantinople
um so like so he goes east he goes and
he goes back to jerusalem and he kind of
like
you know the the the circle sort of it
brings it kind of brings it together
yeah it brings it together so so it's a
cool way to see how
something like um something like popular
literature drama
veneration all these things um in the
middle ages were able to tie into and
down to just like
uh ornamentation on architecture we're
able to tie into the universal history
in this way yeah
all right so this is this has just been
great just one more example and a very a
very kind of thoughtful example
of universal history and also an
understanding of how we have this
we have a sad virgin of the middle ages
or that period of time where with all
propaganda it was all just you know that
there wasn't the subtlety of
understanding uh that we moderns have
but in this tradition we do actually
find a kind of powerful subtlety in
recognizing the strength and the
weaknesses of our ancestors and
celebrating them
nonetheless and not wanting to cancel
and destroy their memory because they're
not perfect and they're not christ
incarnate you know all of them
right yeah uh it
these takes are wonderfully complex in
in lots of ways and
and yeah there's definitely a
um you could you can think about the
situation that
somebody might find that found
themselves in in the 1300s looking at
this list and being like oh yeah these
are great this is you know and this i
mean this is popular literature right
this is this is like common people were
really into these stories and really
into these figures
and for that person to find themselves
under the rule of a local lord or a king
who was maybe not like perfect in every
respect
but then also you know but also you know
a night a night is still a night like
you know i
i once read this medieval account i
can't remember where it is now
about this man who walked
like a hundred miles
in a week
to go because because he heard that a
certain princess was going to be passing
through the city and he just wanted to
have the experience of seeing a princess
um and it was just like a common man and
and this is the this is a sort of
we can't um
we can't conceive now of something like
that i mean i guess people will go to
see celebrities things like that but we
also we also sort of like
they would have thought of like a
princess as being like in some ways like
like like ontologically different like
seeing a princess is really different
from seeing a woman right
there they're not
totally the same thing
and uh so so if you're if you find
yourself like under one of these these
guys who's
not
uh
not the best
but then you can still see that he
participates in these certain aspects of
the chivalrous king the chivalrous man
the perfect knight and and participates
in them and just to some greater or
lesser degree you can kind of celebrate
and give your attention to those parts
of his life yeah not these other parts
i'll i'll just close with this um
talking about godfrey
it says and this is the end of the book
it says he was a prince in whom all
virtues christian civil and military so
those are the three kinds of virtues
that each of these guys represent to
some degree christian virtues civil
virtues military virtues met in the
highest point of humane perfection
without mixture of any default
so that it will remain difficult to find
another like to him whom without
flattery the same praises may be given
and which induced future ages to bestow
upon him the honorable title of one of
the worthies of the world
that's great great way to end and so
richard thanks for thanks for your time
as usual and everybody else stay tuned
we've got
we've got an indefinite amount of these
you know who knows how long we're going
to go but we're as long as we enjoy it
and you enjoy it we're going to keep
going so so everybody thanks for your
time and uh we'll talk to you very soon
thanks everyone